[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Annabeth Gish AKA
Billy and Little Dixie which is in
theaters and on demand now how you doing
today Annabeth I I'm good I'm good I'm
I'm battling a little bit of a sinus
infection but I
so that's why I'm all clogged up but
otherwise I'm great Oh no you're a
trooper for being here then thank you
for joining uh I love it
um so for a character like Billy though
just for you in general with roles
you've done what is the first thing you
do to prepare for a character like Billy
well what I love so much about this this
was kind of a um a late in the game ask
for me to join the film uh from Jeremy
Rosen who I've worked with before and
and I immediately jumped at the chance
because I loved the idea of a character
you know Billy who is a campaign advisor
who's
dirty kind of a dirty dirty cop kind of
a character and isn't
um doesn't necessarily play by the rules
so which is difficult when you're
working with the cartel
oh no 100 it's a really fascinating part
too and you do it great and I like what
you're saying too she's a little dirty
it's interesting watching her in this
film too because you want to know more
about her as it goes on
um
I'm interested to know too because
you've played so many characters is when
you're playing a role like Billy do any
prior characters you play before
reappear like do you find things you
used in a character you've played before
in the new characters that help in any
way absolutely that's a great question
yes for sure I think um as with anything
uh and and with maturity as we go with
experience and all kind of a cruise and
builds up and and for Billy I felt you
know she's kind of a combination of my
character in West Wing and also Sons of
Anarchy you know she's a badass
um but she knows how to speak
politically and it doesn't get her get
her to a good place in this film but but
you know to have some cojones you know I
I really do especially these days like
to play women who have some balls
so running off of that then when you're
doing acting just today and you've done
it for a while what keeps it fresh for
you like do you ever feel like getting
stale like or do you still have that
same like excitement for every part you
do now
well you know I am fortunate in the
sense that I endurance is a a gift to be
able to to kind of still be around and
still find it fresh I would I would
generally see generally say yes I do try
to keep it fresh and exciting and if
there's something I don't want to do I
just say no you know yeah that that
luxury in this day and age too I mean it
really has to mean something for me to
take time away from I have two teenage
sons and
um my family so you know it's hard for
me I have to that's the criteria is it
worth taking the time away from my
family have you ever regret like saying
no or do you find that mostly when
you've said no you're you're happy you
stuck with that uh well I'm sure there
are things along the way well there
there are also things that have said no
to me
it's called rejection
that has happened once or twice
um but I think you know I do find I do
have to take a kind of a
sensibility of of what is for you will
find you and what you're meant to be a
part of and I'm so happy that this kind
of fell into mind that because I love
the movie I think it's just this
Unapologetic throwback
um action thriller I think Frank is so
watchable and Eric is strong and Beau
nap is incr you can't take your eyes off
him in this role yeah so interesting
yeah it's a fun cast and it's a fun film
and I like that it's an action thriller
and it's cool seeing you in that and
I've Loved recently all the horror work
you've done too in particular the
flanniverse uh universe so is there a
genre
um you find right now you have the most
Joy doing or do you kind of just feel
like you've you like all of it uh well I
am definitely multi-faceted I never
thought that I would be in uh the horror
Niche but back I have I've now done I
think like three Stephen King projects
and then four Mike Flanagan projects so
it's a I guess my sensibility agrees
with it
um but I'm
I will say that maybe between a lot of
all of the flanning and stuff and then
recently maker which is which has a
horror element too
I think I'm a little I need to take a
little bit of a break from the special
effects genre yeah
just my psyche I've been in a casket
more times than I care to be lately so
sure
um
Little Dixie I you know
no but also too though have you like
with all these different kind of Vibes
you've done in different genres and
things you've experienced have you ever
thought of Dipping into writing or
directing and doing something behind the
scenes ever
yes I have um I've I've optioned a a
novel and written the screenplay for it
and yeah especially in my as my children
get getting older yeah I definitely want
to pursue that Avenue next yeah that
that that's that's really exciting to
hear and
um I'm also too because you mentioned
Mayfair witches so it's an exciting year
for you with that but also that you're
going to be in succession season four so
do you get as excited to watch these
projects you work on as much as the fans
like do you like when you're feeling the
watch succession that Sunday and like
well
um
I have a hard time watching things that
I'm in with other people okay well maybe
my husband and I will but um and my kids
are kind of unimpressed overall
[Laughter]
um but but I think no for sure I'm I'm
I'm always very excited when I'm when I
join a show or I'm working on something
that has a uh I mean succession is like
the most incredible show right now so
yeah I was I was very happy to do this
little stint is there something too like
with doing shows like that but also with
Little Dixie where you're in this cast
with Frank Grillo and Eric Dana like I
imagine you guys get close on a film
like this but then like you go your
other ways like is there
like do you have you learned not to get
too close maybe is there like a sad
thing to that well certainly when I was
younger that was you you have to kind of
uh adjust to that ethos because you live
these mini lives in a very short amount
of time kind of gypsy lifestyles
uh but the one thing that I think yes
that's true you get close and then you
separate but uh the world is quite small
and I've known both Eric and Frank for a
long time and and I love it when these
kind of you get these like oh hey how
are you you know it's been like it's
just it recircles back it's around
itself it's lovely oh I I really like
that answer and um
the last thing I'm gonna ask you before
you go just about Little Dixie too just
as an actress is there anything that you
will take away the most from this
experience in Little Dixie when you look
back at occur that like stuck with you
or you'll keep with you
well you know honestly it was uh filming
in Tulsa with John Schwab was a treat
because it was again
it was exactly what it they said that it
was it was unapologetically this gritty
film John is super smart he knows what
kind of movie he's making
Frank I I loved working with him and I
like Tulsa I would go back to Tulsa in a
heartbeat yeah no that that's really
cool it's cool to hear that you guys
filmed in Tulsa so just all the great
information you gave me this was a great
interview and there's a lot to learn
from this so thank you for opening up to
me I really appreciate everybody watch
Annabeth kill it in Little Dixie in
theaters and on demand now thank you so
much for joining me I hope sucks again
in the future thank you Steve